okay let's get into audience questions
for the week first one is
hey david everybody's obsessed with
critical race theory but do its critics
even understand what it is
some of them do and many of them don't i
saw one conversation
uh with mark lamont hill and
uh i don't remember who the other guy
was where the other guy had no idea
whatsoever
we covered it the other guy had no idea
whatsoever what critical race theory was
and every time mark lamont hill said
okay fine you're against it but what is
it
the guy deflected he clearly had no idea
i saw a different conversation that mark
lamont hill
had with a guy from some sort of i think
it was like a center-right thing tank
not one that i was super familiar with
and the guy could at least list some
people who he believed
were influenced by critical race theory
even though mark lamont hill said those
aren't real
really critical race theorists and he
had
some more connection now you could argue
i disagreed with the guy or i agreed
or whatever but there are a lot if
you're asking me about
your aunts posting stuff to facebook
about critical race theory
most people don't know what it is and
it's not an insult
or an attack critical race theory much
like many of these theories
mostly exists in the academic world so
it's it's sort of expected and natural
that tons of people wouldn't know very
much about it it's just become
popularized through controversy such
that you have a whole bunch of people
who know nothing about it
who are talking about it anyway now i've
i've given my perspective before
on on what it is and what i think about
it that is valuable and less
valuable and a whole bunch of people got
mad and wrote to me and many said
that's not really what it is or you're
sort of partially right or whatever the
case may be
um i think that at a certain point there
is a sort of no true scotsman fallacy
you get to with a lot of these things
and this was
this is really common with jordan
peterson and his followers actually
where anytime i would try to do a
critique of something jordan peterson
said
a significant portion of his followers
wouldn't actually engage with what i say
but rather would claim that's not really
the position of jordan peterson you're
bastardizing what jordan peterson said
and to some degree this is happening on
both sides with critical race theory
there
are people who when confronted with a
reasonable critique of critical race
theory as it applies to some aspects of
society
will say you're not being honest or you
don't understand what it actually is
and then you either have a conversation
about what it actually is
which sometimes goes somewhere and very
often doesn't i've seen some
some online live debates about it where
they can't even define what it is and
it's just
a worthless waste of three hours and
that's sad
but you also do have people on the right
who reflexively oppose it in total
even as a framework for analyzing any
aspect of society
while having absolutely no idea what it
is i think the best thing
to do first and foremost is just
understand the structure and let the
other person tell you
what it is you think they believe it
says
about society so critical race theory
much like most critical theories has its
basis
in foucault post-modernism
post-structuralism you could argue argue
jean-paul sartre the the the framework
should at least
generally be understood the importance
of language and the way we talk about
things within such theories you should
generally have an understanding of
um it's it's connection to economics
and there's and again this is where some
some people will go nuts so i even
hesitate to say this but
you can you can make the case that the
type of analysis
has some roots in marxist
thought now it doesn't mean that
to believe in critical race theory you
have to be a marxist in a literal sense
it's just
we're talking about some of the overlaps
um and most people don't know that
most even even just these basics most
people do not know
the right is caricature caricaturing
critical race theory as it's the story
that
all whites are racist or even white
supremacists
and that's the lens through which
everything must be seen
period full stop that's an unfair
caricature of critical race theory
there's plenty to criticize about
critical race theory based on a real
understanding of it
there's really no need to go to nonsense
stuff like much of the right is doing
but to answer the question do critics of
critical race theory even understand it
if you're talking about what you're
seeing posted to twitter and facebook
and much of social media and even what's
happening on fox news
the answer is no the vast majority
do not understand it during the pandemic
and even at this point
i try to avoid physically visiting a
doctor's office unless i really have to
and that's why i love our sponsor
steadymd primary care you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician who's a good fit for you
you have a one hour virtual appointment
and you start
a meaningful relationship with your new
doctor after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone and video chat and
unlike other services this isn't some
random doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they can give you
the personal attention you deserve
they can help you with anything your
primary care doctor
normally would healthy diet managing
conditions weight loss
sleep depression anxiety you don't need
insurance
it's just 99 a month with absolutely no
other fees or co-pays for visits
take the free quiz and see which doctor
is a perfect fit for you
go to steadymd.com pacman there's no
risk
no long-term commitment the link is
right underneath this video